vous voulez d'Airbus Industrie et de
vous-même je vous demandais de changer
un petit peu de place de faire 5 mètres
car Daniel grand Clément qui est là-bas
vous attend pour le crible d'antenne de
midi
et les aspects négatifs pour voir un peu
ce qui va moins bien c'est d'aller grand
Clément donc le procureur pour cette
émission
vous êtes l'invité donc d'Antenne 2
parce que vous avez réussi maintenant si
on regarde un petit peu votre carrière
le déroulement de votre carrière on
s'aperçoit que vous étiez directeur des
transports aériens quelques années et
que donc vous étiez un petit peu
responsable du programme Concorde de ce
côté là c'est moi bien marché comme
directeur transporteria j’étais
responsable des problèmes de négociation
de droit de trafic de la tutelle des
compagnies aériennes des programmes qui
ont encore des Airbus et CFM 56
j'étais responsable en tant que
président du Comité intergouvernemental
Airbus et en tant que du comité
directeur Concorde qui était la même
chose
en ce qui concerne le Concorde je pense
que cet avion n'a pas de chance
il n'a pas eu de chance parce que quand
il a été lancé en 1962 les conditions du
marché étaient radicalement différentes
de celles qui la rencontrer au moment où
il est sorti en 1962 très peu de gens
parlaient d'écologie la crise des
carburants n'était pas encore arrivée le
bruit autour des aéroports tout le monde
s'en moquait et je signale quand même
que la viande devait sortir en 1969 vous
étiez partisan donc de concorde n'avez
jamais mis de réserve
je n'avais pas aimé de réserve je n'en
aurai pas aimé je pense que c'est une
chose que je n'ai pas regretté et que
personne n'a regretté je pense
d'ailleurs que nous tirons sur l'Airbus
les leçons de l'expérience Concorde vous
me direz que c'est une formation un peu
chère
mais c'est une chose qui est excellente
et qui a donné à la belle de qualité
à la maîtrise européenne mais vous êtes
toujours partisan des supersonique je
suis toujours partisan du supersonique
je pense simplement que la prochaine
génération n'est pas pour demain un
avion est en général bâti autour d'un
moteur et arrivé à trouver un moteur qui
soit économique qui puisse faire voler
l'avion à MacDo ou trois et qui en même
temps soit pas bruyant autour des
aéroports c'est une performance
technique telle que je ne pense pas
qu'on arrive à faire quoi que ce soit de
sérieux avant les années 90 ce point de
vue là alors certains constructeurs ils
pensent mais ils y consacrent des sommes
extrêmement limitées alors vous disiez
tout à l'heure que vous étiez là en tant
que carbus industrie au nom de l'équipe
Airbus industrie et pourtant la sans pas
tellement cette équipe autour de vous
lorsque nous sommes rencontrés pour
préparer cette émission par exemple vous
avez un petit peu parlé de vos
collaborateurs mais pas tellement et on
n'a pas tellement cité le nom de Roger
bétail qui pourtant elle est peut-être
le véritable créateur du projet d'Airbus
écoutez la presse les journaux les
livres tout ce que vous voudrez je dis
toujours quand je vais faire le
véritable père de l'Airbus il est pas là
aujourd'hui parce qu'il rentre des
Philippines alors j'ai préféré qu'il
reste chez lui tranquille notre
directeur commercial est en Australie le
directeur de la production est en
Allemagne nous voyons constamment mais
je peux vous dire qu'au contraire nous
avons une équipe qui est extrêmement
soudée précisément peut-être parce que
c'est une équipe internationale dont
j'ai eu le choix on ne m'a jamais imposé
de choisir tel ou tel de mes directeurs
en fonction de sa nationalité
jusqu'à présent et quand je serai là ça
sera comme ça j'ai pu obtenu d'obtenir
de les choisir en fonction de leurs
compétences vous pensez vous espérez
vendre un millier d'Airbus actuellement
vous en produisez vous en produisez
pardon 3 par mois et si tout va bien 8
en 1984 ce qui est disproportion un peu
étonnant non pas du tout parce que nous
passerons à 10 en 85 10 avions par mois
ça vous fait en campagne ils ont produit
28 par mois oui il s'agit de plusieurs
types il y a des longs courriers nous
n'en n'avons pas il y a des petits
avions nous n'avons pas vous avez 737 et
727 le 707 le 710
ou même pas nous avons été créé en
décembre 70 donc ils ont eu le temps de
développer des types différents je
signale quand même que
les coûts de Recherche et Développement
du 310 bien que ce soit un modèle dérivé
donc pas cher sont égaux à ce dernier
Anne c'est un milliard de dollars et il
écoute développement pour le 300 c'était
également ça donc on ne peut pas
demander au contribuable de lancer tout
à la fois mais si ça marche pourquoi
à la fin de l'année prochaine il faut
déjà que les bureaux d'études digèrent
le 310 qui lui va sortir en 83 donc il
est nécessaire que la charge de travail
puisse être répartir en différents
projets et puis à partir du moment où
vous produisez entre 90 et 100 avions
par an un avion qui sera produit et qui
sera vendu jusqu'à l'an 2000 si vous
arrivez à multiplier 100 par 20 vous
devez y arriver je pense on arrive à
deux fois 1000 donc je pense pas qu'il y
a de problème mais par exemple vous
investissez plutôt de moins en moins
vous investi par exemple pour le
lancement de l'Airbus du premier Airbus
vous investi 5 milliards de francs un
milliard de moins pour le B10 pourquoi
pourquoi cette timidité un petit peu que
l'on sent ce n'est pas du tout une
timidité c'est que la situation n'est
pas la même le nouvel Airbus E310 est un
dérivé de l'avion existant c'est le même
fuselage c'est les mêmes moteurs
simplement l'aile change je signale de
surcroît que l'avion sera construit sur
la même chaîne donc dans les
investissements qui ont été faits pour
le premier type d'avion il y avait par
exemple toute une chaîne de montage
flambant neuve et arrive le moins cher
alors que là on va se contenter d'un ou
deux postes de plus il faudra un second
rôle de peinture à l'Aérospatiale à
Toulouse parce que l'actuel n'a pas que
4 avions par mois il faudra un autre
abreuvoir c'est c'est l'endroit où les
avions sont remplis mais je veux dire
les exigments les investissements sont
relativement limités par rapport à ceux
qui étaient nécessaires pour un avion
entièrement nouveau et c'est là notre
chance par rapport à ce que notre
concurrent américain 767 qui lui doit
investir sur un avion totalement neuf
des sommes considérables qui sont 3 à 4
fois supérieur aux notes merci le procès
est terminé
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle elle vous
annoncer depuis le début de ce journal
nous attendions mais vous le saviez une
liaison directe par satellite avec notre
envoyé spécial en Iran jacabusha pour
faire le coin et bien je viens de
l'apprendre alors que tout était prêt
que tout le monde était finalement
d'accord aussi bien les Iraniens que les
responsables des télécommunications
françaises toute la technique mais nous
n'avions pas nous n'avons pas de liaison
satellite il est américain satellite et
les Américains les journalistes
américaines l'ont réservé et pour toute
la journée une prise d'otage en quelque
sorte on peut peut-être dire aujourd'hui
c'est Ariane était né plutôt non
monsieur Curien était né plutôt on
aurait peut-être plus de satellites
européens et français déjà dans l'espace
mais nous en aurons bientôt et puisque
le gouvernement français a décidé cette
année de se doter pour les années qui
viennent d'un système de
télécommunication spatiale télécommande
puis d'un système de télévision spatiale
puis d'un système d'observation spatiale
donc nous marquons vraiment à partir de
80 un départ énorme de nos activités
dans l'espace en France et en Europe
Ariane comme Airbus c'est un succès
européen c'est un conglomérat de société
c'est le deuxième exemple de réussite
européenne
mais justement avant disons que les
synthèses on a retrouvé que les grosses
difficultés ils savent que maintenant on
en récolte les bénéfices absolument nous
avons d'ailleurs constaté à propos de ce
premier tir d'Ariana Kourou une
véritable cohésion entre toutes les
équipes que ce soit les équipes du côté
de l'état du CNES ou du côté des
industriels de tous les industriels qui
ont travaillé à ce programme et une
cohésion aussi entre tous les pays
d'Europe qui ont fait de d'Ariane leur
programmer on sent cette cohésion quand
tout va bien on s'aime et puis c'est
tout où on sait mon renseignement et
quand les choses sont un peu difficiles
on voit vraiment si on sait mais bien là
on a vu que tout le monde voulait ce
programme réussisse et il a réussi et on
l'a vu parce que il y a eu quelques
difficultés il y a eu quelques
difficultés qui sont tout à fait
naturelles quand on a un programme tel
que celui-là on essaie tous qu'on peut
au sol alors on essaie tous qu'on peut
des différents étages de la fusée les
différents systèmes d'affusés et puis on
fait toutes les perfecter tous les
perfectionnantes toutes les corrections
qui sont nécessaires et puis on essaie
tout ce qu'on peut désinstallation de la
base de lancement tout et puis on amène
le lancement le lanceur sur la base de
lancement et voilà maintenant il faut
tester l'interface entre ce qui se passe
entre le lanceur lui-même et la base de
lancement alors là on ne peut le faire
que lors du premier essai en vol alors
naturellement on découvre là toutes
sortes de prise imperfections et il faut
y faire face extrêmement vite parce que
quand le décompte est lancé il y a des
points de northo alors c'est là que on
sent vraiment que les gens en veulent
qui se connaissent leur programme qui le
connaissent à fond et qui sont les uns à
côté des autres et c'est pour qu'on a
réussi comment avez-vous réagi à
certaines ironies disons des
journalistes de tous les journalistes
nous aussi le genre de titre Ariane la
fusée sol c'est amusant mais vous réagi
amusant à la limite pas tellement pour
ceux qui étaient dans le bain et qui
avait à réussir mais enfin il faut en
prendre le côté amusant et l'essentiel
c'est de réussir vous adressez aux
problèmes de satellite de fus
c'est d'arriver à tenir une équipe dans
les affaires marchent pas nous en 76
nous avons vu un seul avion on a réussi
à tenir une équipe internationale et je
crois que le point fondamental c'est
d'avoir une autorité centrale dans ses
programmes et qui soit vigoureux ils
savaient justement en parler de concorde
tout à l'heure c'est ce qui a manqué
dans le système de Concorde où il y
avait quatre industriels pratiquement à
égalité et avec le système de comité ça
sans exécutif qui pourrait prendre les
décisions et je crois que dans le
programme Ariane et comme dans le dans
le nôtre c'est un point très important
je crois aussi que ces deux programmes
sont l'exemple de ce que peut faire
l'Europe quand elle quand elle s'unit
d'autres programmes sont l'exemple de ce
qu'elle peut faire aussi quand elle
n'est pas unie et c'est un des points
importants je crois de
ma réflexion d'aujourd'hui c'est que
entre
le monde islamique 900 millions
d'habitants qui est l'arme du pétrole
qui se réveille et dont je rappelle
quand même contre 632 et 732 ils ont
promené leur cavaliers depuis Médine et
melameque jusqu'à Poitiers date connue
qui ont l'arme du pétrole comme les
Anglais avaient l'arme du charbon au
moment de la première révolution
industrielle qui maintenant
sont fanatisés par un certain nombre de
détonateurs dans l'Iran ou d'ailleurs il
ne faut pas avoir quelque chose
d'extraordinaire il faut quand même se
rappeler nos Français que Robespierre
devait être considéré en 1792 comme
l'ayatollah de l'Europe parce que les
têtes tombaient et puis il amené des
choses que auquel les gens de
s'attaquentaient pas mais quand même il
faut faire attention à cela il faut
faire attention aussi en fonction des
problèmes pénurie d'énergie que cela
pourrait poser au sort des pays vraiment
sous-développés qui n'ont ni pétrole ni
industrie de pointe et qui vont se
trouver peu à peu accumulé la famille à
la fin indirectement liée une pénurie
d'énergie alors entre ce côté explosif
là l'explosion éventuelle dans ces pays
très sous-développés le fait que les
super grands risquent de grignoter
l'Europe dans les domaines d'autres
technologies si nous n'y sommes pas
qu'est-ce qui va nous rester d'ici une
dizaine d'années il va nous rester 50
millions de chômeurs et nos yeux pour
pleurer donc nous sommes obligés d'être
dans ces secteurs de pointe qui par
rapport aux textile d'un concurrence
avec l'Asie pour prendre cet exemple là
est un secteur dans lequel nous pouvons
nous avoir notre place même en face des
super grand
et nous devons le faire parce que c'est
notre c'est notre sauvegarde comme il
s'agit de de projet d'un coup de très
élevé qu'il s'agisse d'Ariane ou de
l'Airbus ou de n'importe quoi d'autre je
ne crois pas que ce sont des choses
qu'on puisse faire maintenant à
l'échelle nationale donc je pense que
l'Union de l'Europe mais vraiment
physiologiquement biologiquement est une
nécessité à la survie d'un certain
niveau de vie et d'une certaine
influence de l'Europe et des idées
européennes de liberté individuelle de
dignité et de fraternité qui doivent
être les nôtres
vous avez été attaquée tout à l'heure
par Daniel grand Clément sur certains
problèmes d'autres personnes vous
attaquent en tant que constructeur
d'avion on dit que vous faites des
engins qui sont bruyants premier
reproche qui sont polluants deuxième qui
sont de gros consommateurs de pétrole de
kérosène après une fois on va rincer un
peu les rôles vous avez devant vous
madame Lepage qui défendait les
défenseurs de l'environnement vous avez
des réponses à donner à toutes ces
accusations
d'abord je n'ai pas le sentiment du tout
qu'on a été
en tant qu'arbus alors attaqué par les
associations de l'environnement au
contraire je peux dire que dans tel ou
tel pays l'aide des associations
environnement nous étaient en quelque
sorte acquises contre la compagnie pour
lui dire laisser tomber vos vieilles
machines bruyantes et puis prenez une
machine moderne non polluante etc en ce
qui compte à l'économie d'énergie
je rappelle quand même un chiffre qui
vaut ce qui vaut c'est l'ordre de
grandeur qui est intéressant c'est que
l'Airbus par passager consomme 4 litres
et demi au sort alors je sais pas si
vous avez beaucoup de voitures qui en
font autant mais c'est quand même très
important sur les problèmes de bruit
bien c'est la viande plus silencieux qui
veulent actuellement on le sait mais
c'est pas moi de le dire j'aimerais
autant que ça vous qui dise est-ce que
vous pensez de ces problèmes d'aviation
et un petit peu difficile lorsqu'on est
en présence de l'Airbus de justement
critiquer car l'Airbus est l'avion qui
probablement a fait le plus d'efforts
dans la protection de l'environnement au
sens large c'est-à-dire précisément le
bruit la pollution atmosphérique disant
que ce n'est pas le problème principal
aux États-Unis je crois qu'on a calculé
à 2 % la part revenant à la pollution
des avions dans la pollution
atmosphérique donc c'est quelque chose
que je considère comme relativement peu
importe où égard aux problèmes de bruit
pour donner quelques chiffres il y a un
à deux millions de Français qui sont
situés à proximité des aéroports
lorsqu'on est situé dans un rayon de 6
km autour d'un aéroport on supporte des
nuisances de l'ordre de 85 à 95 décibels
c'est quand même considérable c'est plus
que considérable et je crois pas que ce
soit uniquement un problème humain c'est
bien ça qu'il faut voir il y a un
problème humain certes mais il y a
également un problème économique et
social de la pollution du bruit car qui
dit nuisance de cette importance dit
conséquences sur la santé des gens sur
l'utilisation des médicaments sur la
sécurité sociale sur l'emploi la
productivité des accidents du travail
sur l'économie proprement dit
c'est-à-dire les logements des gens la
dépréciation de l'environnement etc donc
c'est un problème beaucoup plus large et
je crois qu'il doit être posé en termes
extrêmement large encore une fois
l'Airbus est un des avions effectivement
le moins nuisant et il est beaucoup
moins sonore que c'est concurrent ça je
crois qu'il faut le dire encore moins
bruyant je crois que c'est très
difficile en fin d'après les études que
j'ai vu je ne crois pas que dans les 50
ans à venir on puisse attendre des
avions qui fasse moins de bruit de
l'ordre de 2 à 3 décibels c'est tout ce
qu'on peut espérer vous savez il faut
voir les choses aussi telles qu'elles
sont et
tout à fait d'accord avec ce que vous
dites sur un plan personnel le niveau de
bruit de l'Airbus fait que pratiquement
dans tous les grands aéroports du monde
on n'attend pas l'avion en dehors de
l'enceinte même de l'aéroport on
n'entend pas si je peux voir compter oui
les 25 une histoire très brève quand on
a fait les essais de
bruit ou décollage de l'Airbus on les a
fait faire on les avait fait faire en
Angleterre parce qu'on voulait que ce
soit honnête n'est-ce pas et comme
l'avion n'avait pas des moteurs rolls on
était sûr que les Anglais allaient être
honnêtes
alors l'avion a décollé et puis on
s'attendait à 93 94 décibels ce qui est
en gros le bruit de l'autoroute à peu
près et on est arrivé avec des mesures
qui nous donnent naissance 5 alors dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe recommencer et
ils ont de nouveau recommencé sans 5
regarder les Anglais c'est du sabotage
ils étaient pas encore dans l'opération
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors on a
dépouillé les enquêtes et puis on s'est
aperçu qu'ils avaient mis les micros en
bordure de l'autoroute et que c'était le
bruit de l'autoroute qu'on attendait
dans les micros que l'avion est passé en
dessous il est considéré d'ailleurs
comme un avion 20% moins bruyant que
tous les avions actuellement utilisés
istrot y compris les aérodromes les
aéroports mais ce que vous dites madame
est tout à fait vrai la nouvelle
génération d'avion qui viennent comme le
310 ou le 767 seront un petit peu moins
bruyants que l'Airbus parce qu'ils sont
en gros parce qu'ils sont moins gros de
15 ou 20% mais ça n'ira pas et puis
maintenant nous avons quand même un
temps un niveau de bruit qui est
homogène
par rapport à ce que c'était avant on
arrose 35 fois moins de personnes en
surface qu'un 727 35 fois moins
très rapidement je crois quand même que
le problème du bruit doit être un
problème qui doit être résolu puisqu'on
ne peut pas le résoudre à la source et
bien il faut le résoudre au sol et par
conséquent je crois que ce qu'on peut
demander c'est une politique
d'aménagement du territoire qui soit
beaucoup plus stricte que celle qui est
actuellement
du Musée de l'Homme c'est parce que les
problèmes de l'évolution humaine vous
passionnent
oui et passionne et puis c'était aussi
parce que je pense qu'on vit une période
extrêmement agitée extrêmement
inquiétante pour chacun dans la mesure
où l'étagiter ou on a l'impression que
en disant
l'humanité sa façon de penser la science
elle-même a énormément changé et la
vôtre je crois
en tête puisqu'elle est fait plus de
programme en disant que depuis qu'il
existe
et je voulais à travers ça et peut-être
aussi les problèmes de
d'astrophysique dont on pourra peut-être
parler tout à l'heure essayer de
replacer
comment dire les événements humains qui
nous préoccupent tant alors juste toute
petite dimension par rapport au total et
peut-être vous demander puisque vous
savez ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à présent
si vous avez une idée de ce qui allait
se passer après on a l'impression que
l'humanité est prise dans une mutation
intellectuelle et scientifique
fantastique depuis quelques années et
puis c'est pas en quelques années qu'on
aura changé les gènes les uns ou des
autres sauf si on se met les tripoter
nous-mêmes ce qui apparemment n'est pas
on appelle le sentiment qui a une
dissociation entre l'évolution de
l'homme et l'évolution de sa pensée
technique oui je dois d'abord vous dire
que ces notions de temps sont
extrêmement importantes et que ça ça
m'amuse de vous entendre parler de d'un
quart d'heure de retard du coup l'Airbus
prend un point en moins que ce que c'est
qu'un quart d'heure grand Dieu et
lorsque vous me disiez tout à l'heure
que je n'aurai pas le temps de
m'exprimer j'aurais toujours le temps
puisque on travaille à l'échelle de
l'éternité dans ce dans ce domaine alors
ce qu'on a trouvé depuis quelques années
c'est que l'homme est très ancien
beaucoup plus ancien que l'on imaginait
puisque on imaginait à l'époque où
j'étais à la Sorbonne qu'il avait un
petit million d'années aujourd'hui il
atteint deux trois peut-être quatre
millions d'années c'est à dire qu'on a
multiplié par 4 au moins
son ancienne t d'autre part il s'agit de
l'homme au sens propre du terme mais ses
ancêtres ont estime aujourd'hui que ces
ancêtres ont plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'années donc un des grands
résultats si vous voulez de ces 10 ans
dont vous parliez un petit peu plus
peut-être de la dernière quinzaine
d'années c'est que on s'est aperçu que
l'homme était extrêmement ancien et qui
plongeait très profondément dans le
monde animal et le fait qu'il plonge
très profondément dans le monde animal
signifie qu'il est encore aujourd'hui
extrêmement soumis à toutes les lois
biologiques et c'est un peu ce décalage
dont vous parliez il est bien évident
qu'on est en développement exponentiel
de la technologie mais que l'on demeure
extrêmement soumis aux lois de notre
corps et on n'est pas près de quitter
cette cette contrainte
c'est que l'homme qui était avant
entièrement soumis aux et l'évolution si
tenter qu'elle soit déterministe
l'étape-moi maintenant en sens qu'il a
trouvé le moyen il peut rayer la terre
de la carte s'il en a envie ou si le
s'il se trompe un peu et c'est un peu ça
qui est évidemment
monter alors de quelques secondes en
arrière on va remonter sur les traces de
et les pâtes de Lucie que vous avez
découvert l'origine de l'homme donc avec
Georges Leclerc qui a repris des images
qui viennent je crois d'un secteur bien
particulier que vous connaissez tout
particulièrement les premiers pas de
l'homme donc en retrouvant Lucie
de 3 millions d'années il proviennent
des membres inférieurs de l'un de nos
ancêtres ce n'était pas un singe ni un
gorille ce n'était plus un orang-outan
mais ce n'était pas encore tout à fait
un homme comme on le connaît aujourd'hui
un homo sapiens les chercheurs de
l'équipe franco-américaine ont donc
découvert ces ossements dans une vallée
quasi désertique de l'Éthiopie un genou
et deux morceaux de fémur se trouvant
près de la
hanchements ils ont pu prouver que déjà
à cette époque l'homme marchait sur deux
jambes et non pas à quatre pattes il
mesurait probablement entre 90 et 105 cm
donc il était très petit les chercheurs
qu'il faut une autre passé et qui
reconstitue nos ancêtres grâce à des
minuscules fragments d'os ont donc fait
une découverte très importante
pourtant cet homme ce n'est pas le plus
vieux du monde
la recherche de nos ancêtres est une
tâche très compliquée ou fouillée ou ne
pas fouiller dans le vastement monde
cette fois c'est un géologue qui a donné
des indications précises sur les
nouveaux lieux où aurait pu vivre notre
ancêtre ayant entendu parler des
célèbres fouilles de la vallée de l'homo
que vous voyez ici un géologue français
eu l'idée de rechercher la trace de
l'homme un peu plus au nord près de la
mer Rouge dans la vallée de la Sarre
et à cet endroit j'ai découvert le site
de la Dar qui a fourni les restes
d'hominidés et c'est dans des étudiants
les dépôts sédimentaires des anciens
lacs il y a 3 millions d'années que j'ai
découvert des couches très riches en
ossements et c'est pour et c'est ce qui
a permis la découverte de ces hommes
ce lieu ne fut pas choisi au hasard il
est en fait à la jointure des trois
blocs qui aujourd'hui s'écartent mais il
y a 3 millions d'années la mer Rouge
était probablement un lac et l'homme
dans sa conquête de l'Ouest et peut-être
passer par là
si nous représente si vous voulez la la
carte du monde comme si on faisait un
film cette carte du monde à 5 millions
d'années donne un point en Afrique à 4
millions d'années elle donne quelques
points en Afrique à 3 millions d'années
elle donne un petit peu plus de points
en Afrique et à 2 millions d'années elle
donne tout d'un coup des points en
Europe et en Asie autrement dit tout se
passe comme si l'homme à partir d'un
foyer africain c'était étendu à
l'ensemble de l'ancien monde puisque
l'Amérique n'est atteinte que qu'à une
époque apparemment beaucoup plus récente
comme le font aujourd'hui les animaux
l'homme a dû lutter sans arrêt pour sa
survie dans un milieu hostile du haut de
ses 100 cm il devait affronter des
véritables monstres comme des crocodiles
géants ou des tigres à dents de sabre